why are passwords
so important or why is it important that
we have better ones
than the ones that we do have because
the ones that we do have are
embarrassingly bad
bad passwords are one of the easiest
ways to compromise a system
for somebody who has a very common eight
character password uh
it can literally take less than a second
for a computer to go through the
possibilities and pull that password out
for an eight character password
right right right my password is five
characters
that's not a joke that's bad right
that's really bad
okay so which of these seem like good
options
password but spelt w-e-r-d
this is a joke right uh-huh
no uh yes that would be within uh normal
password dictionaries permutations of
common words but it's misspelt though
so that was the kind of tripwire on it
right it's still
eight characters even if it's not uh
within your password dictionary which
would mean
okay okay okay it was about it's about
it's bad ones it's a bad one
that's why i got some more um one two
three
four but spelt out
that's not gonna help you okay um limp
bizkit forever
with limp bizkit spelled properly but
forever not
that's also not gonna help you okay
really i think the best
the best advice here is to shift your
thinking from past
words to past phrases
think about a common phrase that works
for you
that's too long to brute force and also
make them unlikely to be in the
dictionary
admiral alonso ghost penis 420 yolo
that's pretty good right it's memorable
too
right it's memorable it's got all the
other things you like like characters
and numbers
yolo capital letters obviously i
shouldn't say now i can't use it
it can actually be a lot harder to
remember a password that they
tell you has to be 13 characters long or
something like that it has to have
exclamation points it has to have
numbers it has to have uppercase and
lowercase
letters and things like that than it is
to remember
a simple phrase like margaret thatcher
is 110
sexy wow that is a password that not
even a computer would guess
now you're right okay i get it i get how
important it is
i i fully understand that the problem is
i'm not gonna do it because
it seems hard even though i know it
isn't
you're killing me sorry
you